[Musique]
anne hidalgo pose un problème à bertrand
delanoë il pensait en faire un de ses
adjoints l'hôtel de ville mais voilà
elle a une petite chance d'arracher le
15e arrondissement là bas j'ai assumé
des responsabilités
au ministère du travail auprès de
martine aubry aujourd'hui auprès de
maryse lebranchu je me sens tout à fait
fort mais est prête à assumer un mandat
de maire sinon je me serais pas présenté
à ça je vous le garantis face à elle
c'est edouard balladur qui mène la liste
seguin mais il ne devrait pas se
présenter à la mairie ce serait son
numéro trois flips bouchons je ne sens
pas un élan vers la gauche et verts les
candidats de gauche mais je sens une
inquiétude voire un mécontentement chez
les électeurs de droite qui se traduit
par l'abstention ou par un vote de
protestation par exemple en faveur de
rené galy dejean le maire sortant du 15e
pourrait être invité au second tour
n'ayant pas été investi par le rpr il
présente sa propre liste
je crois que le 15e va défendre son
maire est le faire gagner le candidat
des listes tibiri jean-antoine juin 6 me
du centre national des indépendants le
15e et l'arrondissement le plus peuplé
et envoie le plus grand nombre d'élus au
conseil de paris c'est aussi celui où il
ya le plus de listes qui se présentent
les deux candidats l'extrême droite l
hôtel de ville l'ont choisi comme
terrain d'affrontement jean yves le
gallou pour le mnr et charles de gaulle
pour le front national
les verts bien sûr le mouvement
écologiste indépendant lutte ouvrière et
une liste sans étiquette sont également
sur les rangs
[Musique]